do you wanna know how absolutely fucking insane mom brain is
I just forgot how old I was when I was talking to somebody
and I told them the wrong age
confidently I might add
a lady asked me for an interview and she asked me how old I was
and I was like I'm 38
fine fine and dandy right
she calls back to confirm some details
cause I just wanna double check that you're 38
because I just I found some like
like a conflicting age I guess
and something else that was posted about me or whatever
I'm like no no no
I just turned 38 I'm 37
and I don't even confidently believe this myself um
because I had to Google it
hey Google
if I was born on this day and this year
how old am I
she was like bitch
you're 37
you're 30 fucking seven
it doesn't really matter anymore
but like um for publication sake